how long do you think you're going to
live 60 70 80 years okay we'll give you
a hundred but don't be fooled because
many people died way younger than that
but let's say your cutoff date or death
date is a hundred years then what have
you prepared or thought about what's to
come next now what's my purpose or goal
in telling you this well it's to inspire
you to think deeper into the reality of
this short fleeting transitory life how
many of us have seen friends or family
members that you loved or some that you
even hate it but now they're gone you've
lost them doesn't this rattle something
inside of you to think deeper into where
they go
we were just arguing joking laughing
together but now they're no more we
somehow think that we are going to live
forever in this life as if science is
going to develop a pill that will extend
our lives forever
for those of us who have been living for
some time if you just look at the
process of age something very obvious
when you just look at some of the old
pictures of when you were young but now
we're becoming older we were once full
of strength but now we are going in
Reverse and becoming older and weak you
get into a routine for many of us it
stays the same wake up work work out
hang out sleep some eagerly await the
weekends just to be able to make it to
the bars or the nightclubs were men lust
over women like an animal on the hunt
for his prey and sadly women go to these
places putting themselves on display and
becoming some horny dogs prey waking up
the next day with
nasty hangover feeling guilty and doing
the walk of shame and then just to do
the same thing the next weekend but this
time you might have an STD is this what
life is about fulfilling one's desires
at the expense of losing one soul now
your intuition tells you this can't just
be it baby mama drama sports party play
entertainment alcohol drugs chasing all
the material things there has to be more
to this life than all of these
superficial things an ultimate goal a
true purpose to your existence - why am
i here on this earth and where am I
going when I die you see my goal was to
motivate you to reflect ponder and think
to the reality of this life the reality
of death and the common-sense question
that all of us should be asking what is
the purpose of my life why am I here now
it's up to you to do something about it
thank you for listening subscribe if you
haven't already to the deanship peace be
with you